all right lady midnight yes lady
midnight tell me uh
where you grew up where are you from
originally i'm from la south central i
grew up at 5923 south venice avenue
and tell me about your family
my family my mom was adopted
as me growing up i just thought that
about it
my dad left me when i was two years old
and
it was kind of frustrating because
me not having a father figure in my life
and growing up it was just me and my
sister and my mom
at the time me and my sister would have
never got along so
it was kind of frustrating and hard
because
my mom would do things and to piss me
off
and she called my sister and my sister
was seeing him beat me up as a kid
and
i used to run away from home i was in
foster care i was in placements
um your mom lost your wife because of
drugs
no i didn't start doing drugs until i
was like
14. no but your mom my mom i i found
that she was doing crack okay i didn't
know she was doing crack until she died
um
it's a lot of things i found out after
she died you know and she died in 2011
on valentine's day
so
and i was in jail when she passed away
and
before my mom died you know
me and my sister was never the closest
sister that was supposed to be
and
it was frustrating and it was hard you
know i was hurting
i was out on the streets
at the age of 18 because my mom put a
training order on me
why would your mom put a restraining
order because she didn't want me in the
house and she knew i wasn't going to
leave
because she was sick
and
she knew i wasn't going for it like so
the only way for her to get me out the
house was sitting here putting strength
water on me
and
i was really hurt when she did that
um
there's a lot of things that my family
just ain't [ __ ]
my grandmother is about to pass away
[Music]
it's just hard like life is hard i'm a
gangbanger
like
i started gaming at the age of 12.
because i saw and i just sit there
i feel like
my mom just didn't want me
or your dad
my dad left me at two years old so
he didn't want me either but he had the
audacity to call me call my grandmother
and my mom to see her see where i was at
when i was 21.
and
he's just talked down about my mom like
he hate her
like call her all type of [ __ ] and
i don't want to hear all that
like i don't you only get one mom
a father yeah you can get a father
anytime because it's always a male fair
somewhere
but you cannot replace a person's mother
period
and i feel like
you know
my loved ones that see him
that i after my mom died
my play brother that was my big homie
sit here die he got shot
and i lost my other half like
ever since i lost my behalf
this is i've been going down here i've
been doing drugs i just been going
downhill
like i just
gave up like going to jail
doing all types of stuff that i'm not
supposed to be sitting here doing
i'm not myself
it's like god is taking people away from
me that i love
and i don't understand it do you see any
options you know being a young girl
growing up in south central did you see
friends that went to college and did
things like that
yeah
but i was the only one that i dropped
out of school
so
i didn't finish
and that led you to the streets yeah
and prostitution and
still prostituting like
doing drugs
gang banging and
a wildlife i live
people lying on me it's just so much
stuff that i go through every day what
is all that lifestyle did he do
emotionally it hurts
it makes me go crazy
it makes me angry
because it's stuff that i could i wish i
could change and i can't
how would you describe a good day for
you what does a good day look like
a good day to me would be
like today no problems no [ __ ]
no drama
like i don't like drama
i'm a cool person
i'm down to earth
i'm outspoken
you know
i'm a goofy person like i like to have
fun
but i don't like to [ __ ] and i mess
up my whole move yeah there's a lot of
that down there
a lot of hustlers up mm-hmm i didn't
have pimps before
i didn't had drug dealers like you know
i said i was drug dealing selling it all
types of stuff like
i did everything went to alaska received
packaging
now i'm dealing with the feds like i'm
dealing with a lot of [ __ ]
like
but only person has been keeping me up
is god
because i believe that
i'm supposed to be dead by now
do you have kids
i have seven kids seven kids
yes are you raising them
no my uh sister has three of them
my friend of a family has two of them
and my other twin boys are in the system
you talk to the kids that are with your
family
i talk to the ones that my sister has
yeah how many different dads
four four
are they in their kids lives no no
unfortunately not no
and that's another thing i'm going
through with them like
you they don't do what they're supposed
to do like as being a father like
don't have kids if you can't take care
of your responsibility
that's how i feel like what i see from a
lot of the stories especially in south
central is
there's no good role models it's not
like did you ever see a a good romantic
relationship
no not none of them
and it's hard to find him you don't even
know what that looks like no
i always been an abusive [ __ ] or dad or
a father figure that was being mentally
physically abusive relationships
it's not one relationship that i have
not fought in
i sit here and got fought at
are
physical
or
mentally are
verbally
abused from
and that hurts
when a person is looking for love and at
the end of the day you just feel like
you're never going to get it
and it hurts
sometimes i be feeling lost
like i feel like everybody gets me
so now i feel like my family is against
me like
where do you stay down
i'm i stay on the streets
playing i don't
but i'm trying to work on getting my own
place again
like i used to stay in vegas
but i'm trying to get my place again
and
get me another car
and just do me just take care of my
family which is my sister my nieces and
nephews and my kids that my sister
do what i can
i have to get myself together before i
can do anything for my kids or my family
but sometimes i put them first before i
put myself first sure
what's been the lowest point of your
life
what's the lowest what's been the lowest
point in your life
is it now
is it now
like probably this time right now
what's likely now
i never would be doing this like i never
would be sitting i always have a car
or sitting i always have my own place
like
i feel like
certain things i just give up like
but now i'm trying to sit here and build
myself back up to see her just start
getting out the way and just
leaving people alone
because i end up hurting somebody
how old do you know huh
how old are you i'm 32 you're 32.
32
7 kids
baby daddies ain't [ __ ]
i just caught them sparring arms
are you saving money at all or probably
not if you don't have i save money like
my get my sister just put it on her
credit card to save for me and stuff
like that yeah
you know
but sometimes i don't you know
want to bother her
because she already dealing with a lot
she got four kids and i got three she
got my three and she got her four
so
she already going through a lot
as it is so
i don't like to ask her for anything i
don't like her to do anything for me
because she got my kids
yeah
do you have any friends
i don't feel like i have friends
i feel like i have fake friends yeah
it's amazing how many people i interview
from these neighborhoods and nobody says
they have any friends
i have friends that's fake
i don't have friends
because if a person can talk to you cool
and then that's when you know they talk
[ __ ] to you
talking bad and down about you that's
not your friend
that's not your friend
but
just like what can i say like
i feel like people hate on me like i'm
just me
people just
i don't know
you got people that like me that respect
me you got people that don't
you have people that sit here and hate
on you
and they don't know why they don't like
you or they just don't like you
but they don't have no reason why they
don't like you
they don't know why
so no i don't have any friends
you ever been in love
have you ever been in love have you ever
been in love
yeah
but that person was never alive
like i'm still in love with this person
but
he got to get himself together because
i can't keep doing going through the
abusive and sitting here and keep you
verbally and you putting your hands on
me and throwing [ __ ] at me like no i'm
not about to keep going through that
like
and you
cheating you going around [ __ ] up the
[ __ ] like
i can't do it
and it's like
i want the best for that person
but they gotta want the best for
themselves
no matter what i sit here and do for
them it seems like it's never enough
like they don't care
if i get my ass up they're not gonna
care they're not gonna jump in or
nothing
and it's sad
what do you worry about
what are you afraid of
dying
which happens a lot down there
dying off for something stupid
and dying over he said she said
over dick and [ __ ]
just stuff like that
you still have hope of getting your life
together and getting your kids back like
that yeah
i have a little bit old
i have a little bit of hope
i have legal guardianship with my
one-year-old reunification with her
but i just need to be in my own place
it's hard to be able to get her back and
do what i have to do
but until then
you know i just
i hurt every day
i want to cry every day
because i'm tired
yeah it's an exhausting life friend
this [ __ ] gets tiring it should get old
like
stuff that people do is like i did it
before already and it's and i see it
again it's like grow up like and i grew
up already i passed by that already
when i used to hold
i almost died like three times
getting into a trick car they tried to
pull a knife for me try to rape me and i
made it out
and by and again and again so that's
three times it happened to me
and i'm still sitting here out there
getting money to this day
but now i'm doing stuff differently
instead of moving fast like that and
taking anything and getting anybody car
i'm taking cautious of who car i get in
other than that
i think ever since my best friend
my day one my big homie
died
that's when i went downhill
that's when i started saying [ __ ]
everything
what would you have done differently if
you could have
i want to be doing drugs
i probably have my kids
i'd be in my own place i have two three
cars
my mom probably still living
but i don't sit here
and regret the life that i have because
everything happens for a reason
i didn't plan it maybe god knew i was
going to do it regardless
it's just something that happened
you never know
what's gonna happen
and to you
until it comes to you
and that's how it loses you work
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned
in your
in your life
to do things differently
to
not go back
on the same [ __ ] that i was doing
before
i'm getting older i'm like no younger
and i am a mother now so
my kids is reason why i'm trying to
change
if it wasn't for my kids i'd probably be
in a penitentiary or in the grave right
now
all right lady midnight thank you so
much for sharing your story you're
welcome i wish you the best of luck
thank you thank you very much
you